between Netflix Amazon cable networks
and every other way to watch TV these
days there's a real wealth of great
stories out there for fantasy fans many
of which have been on the air for some
time so whether you're looking for
fairies witches or ancient gods here are
the best fantasy shows that you still
might not be watching Amazon has made a
few splashy entries into the fantasy
genre over the last few years but
carnival Row might be their most
ambitious project yet based on a film
script by showrunner Travis Beacham the
show tells the story of a mythical world
where a group of supernatural creatures
called Fae are forced to integrate into
human society after war strikes their
community naturally this creates plenty
of discord between the two populations
especially considering that humans are
immediately distrustful of this group of
powerful magical beings of course it
also doesn't help that there's a
supernatural serial killer running
around either the show is packed with
plenty of star power including Orlando
Bloom cara delevingne and jared harris
so if you're looking for a series that
beautifully blends magic with mystery
and murder then you might just want to
take a stroll down carnival row time
travel is always a great conceit for any
fantasy show since it allows characters
to freely travel across all kinds of
different worlds and eras and stars hit
series Outlander uses this device to
perfect effect based on Diana Gabaldon
book series this adaptation stars
Katrina both as Claire Randall a married
nurse who's just survived World War two
only to find herself transported back to
Scotland in 1743 by a set of magical
stones trapped in a time where women
have no rights or any autonomy Claire
tries to find her way back home but soon
falls for Jamie Fraser a Highlander she
marries for protection as their bond
deepens Claire begins to resist the
chance to return home eventually trying
to manipulate time itself to keep the
two lovers together thanks to its steamy
central romance captivating characters
and exciting story the show has been a
huge success for stars serving as one of
the cable networks biggest hits and
earning rave reviews from critics since
it premiered in 2014 so if you're
looking for romance adventure and
attractive people with British accents
then don't worry Claire and Jamie have
got you covered as one of the most
popular American novelists today nail
caimans work is always ripe for
adaptation and in 2019 Amazon became the
official home of
omens a show based on game ins
groundbreaking collaboration with the
legendary terry pratchet it's the story
of an angel named Ozzy Rafael and a
demon called Crowley who must work
together to stop the impending
apocalypse as they've gotten pretty
comfortable inhabiting their human
bodies on earth ultimately this show has
everything fantasy fans could possibly
want bringing its religious elements and
ethereal action into play in a quirky
whimsical way that thrives on the
chemistry between David Tennant and
Michael Sheen Good Omens was an
immediate hit when it premiered on
Amazon Prime in May 2000 and 19 with
critics praising its humor in particular
with just six episodes now is as good
time as ever to binge this quick funny
series that balances light humour with
the heaviest of stakes to the wound to
the Wow as Good Omens has shown Neil
Gaiman adaptations have proven to be
pretty fertile television ground over
the past couple of years but perhaps the
biggest and boldest of any game in TV
show is American Gods based on his 2001
novel of the same name the show follows
the saga of shadow moon an ex-convict
who's drawn into a conflict between the
new and old gods and as he encounters
leprechauns hammer wielding deities and
the personification of the media he's
shepherded along by mr. Wednesday a
charming yet mysterious conman who sits
right in the heart of this pan religious
war when you strike with white you
should expect the consequences with a
knock out cast and rock-solid story it's
no wonder that American Gods has been a
hit since its premiere in 2017 ever
since Riverdale burst onto the scene in
2017 becoming one of the most talked
about shows on television it's been
clear that somehow Archie comics still
offer a deep well of material to pull
front once Riverdale proved it was a
bonafide sensation showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa teamed up with Netflix to
develop the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina based on another Archie comic
starring Mad Men's very own Kiernan
Shipka the show takes on a much darker
tone than you might remember from the
lighter Melissa Joan Hart Sabrina series
as a half witch this new Sabrina
Spellman is constantly struggling to
find a bridge between our two worlds
putting Sabrina's fantastical identity
crisis at the forefront and mixing that
with romance intrigue action and horror
has proven incredibly successful for
this fledgling show and
in large part to ship cos grounding
performance the series has received
glowing reviews the first adaptation of
Deborah Harkness wildly popular All
Souls trilogy of novels UK series a
discovery of witches premiered with an 8
episode season in 2018 delighting
Harkness fans and newbies alike
initially said at Oxford University the
series chronicles the journeys and
adventures of Diana Bishop a historian
trying to deny her true identity as a
witch who comes across a haunted tome in
the university's library and finds
herself swept into a world of magic and
monsters with the help of a vampire
scientist named Matthew Claremont Diana
must embrace her heritage and fight her
prejudice against vampires as they team
up not only to protect the book but
explore its mysteries to the fullest
though Warner Brothers initially
acquired the rights to a discovery of
witches for film adaptation the UK
Network sky1 eventually bought the
rights turning it into a series of their
own and that seems to have been a pretty
smart move on their part as the show
currently has a 100 percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes if you're not
in the UK you can check out the show on
both AMC and BBC America check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]